break the Congo
a problem
atic
jealous
the order set at Tribune
La Pele solanel
uh Destiny
the laforestation
actual
the description
solution
then
foreign
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
okay
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
majesty King Abdullah the second is
being our Hussein King of the hashemite
kingdom of Jordan your majesty you have
the floor
Bismillah
Mr Secretary General Mr President my
friends
[Music]
foreign foreign
our meetings here carry forward 30 years
of progress in the fight against climate
change
consensus has grown goals have been set
yet the lethal dangers have been growing
even faster
every country
is paying the price and especially so
in the developing world
cup 27 now has an urgent task
to kick-start a new level of climate
action
transformative action
that can achieve tangible results faster
and more effectively
this is Jordan's commitment
climate change is no stranger to us
we share similar climate threats with
the entire region
our rainfall average has dropped by
almost half its levels over the past
five decades
while the watershare per capita fell by
nearly 80 percent
the Dead Sea water levels are declining
by three feet per year
just around seven percent of the water
now flows in the Jordan River
compared to its historic average
Oasis with Rich biodiversity have
disappeared within a few decades
while climate change and zero-sum
policies are raising concerns for the
future of the Nile at the historic
rivers of Mesopotamia
in Jordan's case Rising temperatures and
water scarcity
have put heavy pressure on our limited
resources
resources strained further by a natural
population growth driven by the massive
influx of refugees
the U.N has recognized that Global
refugees and their hosts are among the
most vulnerable to climate change
so to address this crisis
Jordan has put forward a climate Refugee
Nexus initiative
it will prioritize support
for host countries that bear the brunt
of climate change
and I hope you will join us in endorsing
this initiative
my friends destructive climate change
does not have to Define our future
today we have more expert knowledge
better practical tools and more targeted
approaches than ever before
the opportunities are immense if we will
grasp them
let me briefly touch on two important
drivers of success
first is close integration between
climate change action
and economic development
this holistic approach reflects a basic
reality in the 21st century
sustainable Economic Development
requires green resources and practices
and in turn a Greener World must provide
for the aspirations of the world's
people
we are starting to find Solutions
in renewable energy water
decentralization advanced irrigation
Technologies
and shifting to Electric modes of
transportation
today Jordan's green recovery program
goes hand in hand with our economic
modernization vision
we are making the most of our country's
significant solar and wind resources
Jordan is a leader in the region in
clean energy production
with 29 of electricity powered by
Renewables
and we plan to reach 50 percent by 2030.
in the meantime Jordan has boosted our
contribution to greenhouse gas reduction
to double our 2030 goal
and across our economy green focused
Partnerships are set to create new jobs
for a future
of Hope now this brings me to a second
driver of successful climate action
strong collaboration at the global and
Regional levels as well as between
public and private sectors in order to
Target opportunities and match up
resources and capabilities
and one critical area is financing for
developing countries to mitigate
climate damage and adapt to its impact
Jordan with a track record of successful
climate responsive projects is Keen
to serve as a regional hub for green
growth
we are working in partnership with Egypt
Iraq the United Arab Emirates Saudi
Arabia Bahrain
and others to sanction our entire region
in Jordan itself
we offer a wide array of opportunities
for investment in climate smart
initiatives green infrastructure
Electric Mobility agriculture
and other sectors
we have joined with the UAE in Project
Prosperity that will expand clean energy
and water
another Innovative project
is taking place at acaba's Marine Nature
Reserve
where we and international Partners will
be helping find Solutions
to Ocean climate crises far beyond our
Shores
and let me mention one more cause close
to Jordan's heart
the urgent call to save world heritage
sites endangered by climate change
the Dead Sea and the sacred Jordan River
are Treasures of the past and Legacies
for our future
Our Generation
must not be the broken link
my friends good or bad
the world's climate is indivisible
so must we be
in the fight for life on Earth
no one is a bystander
every contribution counts
cop 27 has brought us together to link
forces and stand our ground
we are at the beginning of a long
challenging and Urgent transformation
there may be difficult choices to make
but we need to make them while we can
so let's also together
as a region and as an International
Community
and achieve the green resilient and just
world
our people deserve
thank you very much
[Applause]
I thank you your majesty for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Alex Bongo and dimba
president of Gabon your Excellency you
have the floor
foreign
[Music]
foreign
pregnant
[Music]
Excellence
began to miss you
a Glasgow
concert
foreign
foreign
foreign
sits on the equator
on the west coast of Africa
the tropical rainforest of the Uruguay
Basin cover
88 of our country
as a result of five Decades of strong
Forest governance our deforestation rate
has constantly remain well below 0.5
percent and we are probably the most net
carbon positive country on Earth
since
I made a strong commitment to fighting
climate change since in Copenhagen we
have absorbed almost 1.5 billion tons of
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
as stated in our second NDC Gabon has
committed to remain carbon neutral
Beyond 2050.
in addition
subject to investment in our Force
an appropriate carbon payments we hope
to continue absorbing over 100 million
tons of carbon dioxide per year
we are part of the Congo Congo ogway
Basin often referred to as the second
long
as the second long of the planet
basin so it's almost 10 years of global
carbon emissions
our forests are proving more resilient
could climate change than the other
great Forest basins which makes us the
Airfield long in the planet
despite gabon's High Force High Force
low deforestation status
over the last decade we have reduced our
forest carbon emissions by 90 million
tons resulting in the recent validation
by the UNF CCC of our red Plus Credit
this makes Governors one of the red plus
Pioneers in Africa and was evident
during the Africa climbing week May the
eyes of the continent and indeed the
developing world are focused on the
efforts to commercialize these credits
if we are successful it will encourage
other nations to issue Sovereign rate
plus credits creating the enabling
conditions for us
build on the modest voluntary Forest
carbon markets and capitalize on the
potential of nature to join us in the
fight against climate change
this will be this will be a main theme
during the one force Summit that I plan
to co-host with president macron in
liberville in March next year
ouch
if every nation focuses on its ability
to fight climate change by reducing
industrial emissions optimizing its
agriculture technological innovation and
harnessing the potential of our
ecosystems to absorb blue and green
carbon just as we did with covid-19 we
can come together and find Solutions
rather than differences thank you very
much
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Robert John Charles from
Klein president of Seychelles
your Excellency you have the floor
Mr President
excellencies distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen
just a second
first of all may I on behalf of the
people of Seychelles
express our support and solidarity
with all nations that have experienced
the terrible effects of climate change
lately
we stand by you as you mourn those who
have disappeared
and as you rebuild your towns and
villages
many especially our youth
are asking whether cop is a counting
game
26 27 28.
or whether it is a real countdown to
saving our planet
my wish and prayer
is that we leave shamal Sheikh
the city of peace
with a peace packed with our planet
that we make good decisions and pledges
that will be followed by concrete
actions instead of another set of
promises
that take too long to materialize
like other Islands
our contribution in the destruction of
the planet is minimal
yet we suffer the most
for example the carbon emissions of
Seychelles are very low
and we clean up our CO2
plus that of the world
through our mangroves and sigras Meadows
making us a zero contributor to the
destruction of the planet
and yet our islands are disappearing and
our coasts are being destroyed
it is an honor
for me to stand here in Egypt at cop 27.
to announce that in 2023
sejals will further contribute in
mitigation by moving to 100 percent
protection of all its mangroves and
seagrass Meadows adding to the already
32 protection of our ocean and 50
percent of our landmass
we insist
that the multi-vulnerability index the
mvi
should be the New Order
seeds are vulnerable
and we need access to concessionary
funding in order to defend ourselves
against climate change while fulfilling
the sdgs to give our people a better
life
industrialized nations and
multinationals
must pay greater attention to the loss
and damage agenda
we the oceanic states that suffer the
harsh effects of your activities have to
be assisted in repairing the damage you
cause to us
Seychelles is playing a leadership role
in adaptation and mitigation
we are building strong Partnerships
however small we are
this year we welcome the Ocean Race
Summit to discuss the urgency of saving
our one ocean
later we offered the venue for the first
European blue invest Forum outside
Europe
to put emphasis on financing the blue
economy
and late last month we welcomed Prince
Albert of Monaco and the Monaco research
expedition in the search of resilient
corals and of course we are also active
in promoting the great blue wall project
Seychelles remains a serious partner on
whom the world can count on in the
protection of the planet
my call is for us to be very good
partners
let us give our youth a better planet
and may we leave Egypt with enhanced
hope and commitment to save our one and
only Blue Planet I thank you
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Claus Vena luanis
president of Romania your excellencies
you have the floor
Mr President's
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
the times we live in
are the most challenging in a generation
we Face a war on the European continent
with global effects energy insecurity
food food shortages and economic
instability
these should not divert our attention
from climate change
on the contrary
delivering on climates is key to
addressing many of these challenges and
safeguarding the well-being of present
and future Generations
climate change
is not an abstract concept but the daily
reality with consequences on human
health
nature and the economy
my country Romania
experienced this year's severe drought
with negative implications regarding
access to water food production and
power generation therefore adaptation
efforts are crucial to increase the
resilience of societies and ecosystems
facing climate risks
ladies and gentlemen
Romania fully supports the European
Union leadership on climate change
and or joint commitments to reduce net
greenhouse gas emissions
we must ensure an orderly green
transition with multiple benefits
investments in research development
Innovation development of the green
economy and job creation
furthermore energy access at affordable
prices can be secured through investment
in low carbon energy
resilient networks and adequate
regulation for Renewables
the costs of climate in action
exceeds by far the cost of action
climate change generates economic and
non-economic laws and damage across the
world
fellow leaders
our strongest allies in the fight
against climate change are our citizens
we need to prepare and Empower them for
this battle
the youth in Romania is very motivated
to act on climate change and this
dedication should serve as an
inspiration to all of us
I strongly believe in the power of
Education to generate
climate-friendly Behavior
Education and Research systems need to
be better aligned with climate goals and
equip our citizens
particularly our use with the skills
needed in a low carbon economy and
Society
I look forward to a comprehensive cop 27
outcome
let me conclude by kindly inviting you
to work together on this with
determination and dedication thank you
thank you thank you
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Muhammad Sheikh L gazoon
president of Mauritania your Excellency
you have the floor
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
what is that
is
foreign
[Music]
carbon
ated
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
with nothing
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
for your statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Emmanuel macron president
of France your Excellency you have the
floor
something
is
foreign
perfect
ly yeah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
obligation
preparations
foreign
energetic
the development access
is
acceleration the nuclear
[Music]
Etc
is
foreign
foreign
April
the revolution is
strategies presentations
pleasure
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so the solution is
foreign
disability
foreign
Rhonda
representation
in the Philippines
European initiative foreign
initiative
[Music]
Colombia Philippines
more than one foreign
foreign
International
pruners videos
relationship
s
foreign
mechanism
s
adaptation
is foreign
[Music]
Justice
is
foreign
conceptional
prejudice
Africa
[Music]
Caribbean Pacific Latino America
is
foreign
[Music]
exceptional
as usual
business decision
is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
solution
is
no exceptional
definition
foreign
[Music]
pronto
foreign
Justice
performed
do not mechanism
is
some of them
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement and thank you for the apology
it is my pleasure to welcome our
Excellency Miss Samar
slow Hassan president of the United
Republic of Tanzania
Madame President you have the floor
your Excellency the president
Excellence is Hazel state and government
ladies and gentlemen
Mr President CeCe thank you
for convening us
and for timely for a timely theme
delivering for people and the planet
what an opportune time
to meet right after the covid-19
pandemic
a time to reflect on covenanting effects
to Nature people and prosperity
along with the pandemic came lessons
opportunities
and a powerful reminder of the Nexus
between Environmental Health and Human
Health
a reminder to build back better and
sustainably by retracting our Footprints
towards green transition
our yesterday's in action should not be
our today's excuse because science has
unfolded the skill of this planetary
crisis
in its effects to vulnerable communities
and our cause of action
the coveted 19 lockdowns gave us a
stepping stone towards the right path
this Green Path is sustained sustainable
through transformed and modernized
Industry and infrastructure accelerated
economic diversification and
competitiveness and strengthen
resilience
excellencies
science has shown a direct correlation
between human prosperity and
environmental prosperity
nature-based economy can be our reality
if only we have a shared vision and
leverage opportunities that deliver real
and structural changes
we are in shamal Sheikh
a city in a continent whose economy
realize explicitly on natural resources
a continent where millions of its
vulnerable communities are grappling
with poor Public Health greenhouse gas
emissions and loss of livelihoods due to
severe climatic effects
delays
or concrete delays on concrete actions
to address laws and damage
leaves us with no choice
but to realign our Mega Financial
Resources to build a climate resilient
economy that ensures survival of the
bigger segment of our population that
depends on agriculture for livelihood
and to save the looming decline of our
gross national product of which
agriculture counts for the greater
shares
on another hand in action means risking
our development agenda and prosperity
and thus
in this regard we in Tanzania has in
place
the National Climate Change responsive
the National Climate Change response
strategy and the national determined
contributions would set targets of
reducing greenhouse gases emissions
economy-wide between 30 to 35 percent by
2030.
with an estimated US dollar 19.2 billion
as cost of implementation now the
question is how on Earth on Earth
the country like Tanzania raise this
amount of money for mitigation and
adaptation of the climate effects
nevertheless
showing the political will
Tanzania is continuing to construct and
expand rapid transport Networks
that are expected to reduce more than
900 million tons
of carbon generated each year
we are also
determined to increase the use of
renewable energy sources from 60 percent
in 2015 to 80 percent in 2025.
Tanzania also is committed to preserve
48 million hectares of forest and this
is about 55 percent of the total land
area of the country and on top of that
we are planting 200 million trees in
every three years
all we are asking here is for an
alignment of global carbon prices to
help generate resources from these
carbon sink
Excellence is
this is the type of leadership
exhibited by the developing countries
that lack technological know-how lacking
financial and human capacities having
limited scientific information at our
fingertips
yet with these limitations
our part of the world is asked to choose
life or death
the question is do we have an option
unless we do it together
and in this regard
we urge developing our developed
countries especially the G20 to fulfill
their commitments
we call upon effective implementation of
Technology transfer while unlocking
climate Finance to fund our national
determined contributions
we are also urging the developed world
to raise their subsequent ndc's
Ambitions to hold greenhouse gas
emissions
from crossing the irreversible Tipping
Point of atmospheric concentration of
carbon dioxide
having said that Excellence is
I thank you for your kind attention
thank you very much
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr popular chief M Jamal
Rashid president of Iraq your Excellency
you have the floor
foreign
foreign
Muhammad
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
accepted
I mean
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it is now my pleasure to welcome our
Excellency Miss Suzanne captured
president of Slovakia
your Excellency you have the floor
[Music]
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
this year's external weather across the
world reminds us that it's not just the
next Generations who will feel the
impact of the climate crisis
for too long we talk about the why and
how
now it's time to act we need an equal
focus on adaptation to the changing
climate conditions
on mitigating the negative impact of our
actions on climate
while 90 of our all emissions are
already covered by The Net Zero Target
we are still too far from a collective
success
Global emissions continue to rise
it's not enough to have targets
we must turn them into concrete National
steps that will lead us to need Net Zero
by 2030 Slovakia will cut our greenhouse
gas emissions by 55 percent compared to
2005 level
we are joining the global myth and
pledge initiative and we are starting
the biggest decarbonization of our
economy
this will reduce our industrial CO2
emissions by more than 40 percent by
2013.
that the climate emergency will not wait
until the current energy crisis is over
short-sighted Solutions such as
switching from gas to Coal will only
speed up our planet's destruction
in Slovakia we are sticking to to the
plan to close down coal power plants
next year despite the record Energy
prices
we must move faster towards clean energy
and Renewables including geothermal I'm
glad that Slovakia's talents have
developed solutions that will make the
use of this energy possible anywhere in
the world this is good for our climate
our planet and of course for our energy
security
green transition is neither easy nor
cheap
it will often hit the most vulnerable
the most affected countries need more of
our support to cope
[Music]
adoption of the Paris climate agreement
Slovakia's contribution to the green
Finance has grown almost five-fold
we mainstream climate measures in our
development assistance in Europe Asia
and Africa
in Kenya alone we supported 16 000
Farmers by planting 1 million cashew
trees so their produce is local and
sustainable
but governments alone won't address this
the climate crisis
private and Innovative financing must
step in so everyone does their fair
share
excellencies the climate emergency is
here and now
the ocean levels are rising we are
losing biodiversity at record speed
the global food crisis induced by the
climate change and worsened by Russia's
weaponization of grain exports is
forcing millions of people out of their
homes
this crisis demonstrate our Collective
fragility
our Boulder commitments are better and
faster delivery on our climate targets
must make this scope a milestone
the Milestone which will transform our
Collective fragility into our Collective
resilience thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement and particularly for helping
us manage the time may I view to your
excellencies that we stick to this
stipulated three minutes slot as much as
possible
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr faustin a chance to Adara
president of the Central African
Republic your Excellency of the floor
president
excellence
Arab Egypt excellence
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
permanent
population
International
responsibility foreign
foreign
[Music]
back on
the Republic
an
reference
foreign
[Music]
Tribune
La prison the situation particularly
downloading
conditions
[Music]
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Felipe Jacinto nusi
president of Mozambique your Excellency
you have the floor
senior president
yours
can you privilege you singular
the enormous
there is
[Music]
presents
Egypt
hospitals conditions
your president
felicitor
places
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
movies
he
in Africa
foreign
resilience
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr tanetti mamao President of
kiripat your Excellency you have the
floor
foreign
excellencies distinguished delegates
ladies and gentlemen I begin by sharing
the peace and blessings of the almighty
and the warm greetings of the government
and the people of kripus
Mr President I acknowledge the
government and the people of Egypt for
the warm hospitality and command the
exceptional leadership in hosting these
action-oriented Corp 27. it is indeed a
critical time for us to be more
ambitious in the implementation of the
Paris agree agreement with Solutions
permissible on bothering the resilience
of our peoples against the advanced
impacts of climate change it has been 30
years since the Inception of the UN have
Triple C and despite the science some
continue to block to block ambitions
ambitious actions that could keep Global
emissions and develop effective
solutions to address climate change
impacts consequently for Frontline
countries like kripus this would be
detrimental to our Sovereign desire to
safeguard our people climate change is
happening and loss and damage is very
real yet the major solutions that we
talk about remain distant as we are at
the mercy of multilateral implement
implementing agencies who continue to
determine how we adapt and Access
Financial Resources so disheartening
nevertheless we remain knowful that our
Collective efforts and partnership will
address these concerns we need data
capacity building and Technology
transfer and Country specific science
projections to make our adaptation
planning much more effective
Mr President this declared a state of
disaster to manage and respond the
impact of to the impact of severe
droughts with some of our Highlands
frequently inundated by storm sages the
impact of extreme swing Tides continues
to be a threat to our economy our future
developments and destroying the very
Fabrics of our livelihoods despite these
challenges Mr President our commitment
to building resilience is driven by the
desire of the people to remain living in
Canibus we will continue to strengthen
our legislative and policy Frameworks
including the recently enhanced
nationally determined contributions go
because of maintaining our livelihoods
in the face of climate change
already exceeds our means yet it does
not dampen our resolve to put resources
where we can this is compounded by
covid-19 couples with the inflation on
Commodities including fuel the
government will continue to invest in
building resilience to people send that
approach and social protection programs
Mr President I appeal to my fellow
leaders to stand in solidarity together
to fight this climate dilemma for the
brighter and resilient future of our
Young Generation we must be held
accountable to our climate Finance
commitments and Achieve 1.5 degrees
Celsius to save our share Dome action
begins here and now before it is too
late the nail
retrying health peace and prosperity
upon a soul I thank you
thank you
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement it is now my pleasure to
welcome his Excellency Mr William K Ruto
president of Kenya's speaking on behalf
of the African group your Excellency you
have the floor
okay
Your Excellence is
distinguished delegates
ladies and gentlemen
we come together for the 27th annual
climate meeting 30 years after their
adoption of the U.N framework convention
on climate change in 1992
25 years since we adopted
the Kyoto Protocol in 1997 and seven
years following yet another historic
Milestone the Paris agreement adopted in
2015.
when the convention was adopted in 1920
1992
Global emissions were approximately 27
gigatons
annually this has risen to about 40
gigatons
wild carbon dioxide accumulation in the
atmosphere has also steadily increased
for the past eight consecutive years
documented by the U.N to be the hottest
years in recorded history each new year
has been hotter than the previous year
the whole world is reeling from The
Staggering impact of climate change
the spread scale and frequency of
disasters like hurricanes typhoons
wildfires and heat waves melting sea ice
and Glaciers droughts and
desertification floods and rising sea
levels in numerous regions of all
continents indicate that humanity is
confronting unprecedented devastation
on a global scale
the state of climate
and this of climate in Africa reports
Lay It bear
high water stress is estimated to affect
about 250 million people in Africa and
is expected to displace up to 700
million people by 2030. in the past 50
years
drought-related hazards have claimed the
lives of offer half a million people and
led to economic losses of over 70
billion US dollars in the region
more than one thousand flood related
disasters were reported involving more
than 20 000 deaths in Africa alone over
this period it is estimated that by 2050
climate impacts could cost African
nations U.S dollars 50 billion annually
the owner of Africa region including
Kenya is experiencing the worst drought
in 40 years
two consecutive years without rain have
visited misery on millions of people 2.5
million livestock have died in Kenya
this year alone causing economic losses
of more than U.S dollars 1.5 billion
two days ago we went to dispute food
relief to 4.3 million affected Kenyans
in an emergency program that has forced
us to reallocate funds
budgeted for education and health
the trade-offs we are forced to make
between indispensable public goods is
evident that climate change is directly
threatening our people's lives health
and Future
moreover due to Drought many children
have now dropped out of school we have
been compelled to make school feeding a
priority in order to keep our children
in class
world renowned Wildlife heritage
has not been spared either and carcasses
of elephants zebras wildebeests and many
other wild fauna later our parks
we have had to spend U.S dollars three
million to supply feed and water to
wildlife in the last three months
again
this backdrop
the lengthy discussions at corpse with
its stalling delaying tactics and
procrastination that have hampered
implementation and delivery is simply
cruel and unjust
we cannot afford to spend more time
scutting around the real issues and we
must break out of the open-ended process
focused discussions we are trapped in
further delay will make us busy
Spectators as Calamity wipes out lives
and livelihoods
as we speak
Mr chairman
The Pledge made 13 years ago in
Copenhagen committing U.S dollars 100
billion annually remains unfulfilled
such a gracious and unexplained default
these are major cause of persisting
distrust and neither is there any sound
reason
for the continuing pollution
in stuck contrast Kenya
this then the average developed country
forgone pollution industrialization and
growth opportunities and intentionally
invested in green energy
it must be recalled that Kenya has
tremendous hydrocarbon and coal deposits
which could go a long way in fueling the
engines of our development
nevertheless
due to Resolute commitment our
electricity greed is 93 percent green
this morning we signed a framework
agreement for collaboration on the
development of sustainable green
Industries in Kenya with an investor to
produce 30 gigawatts of green hydrogen
in Kenya
there exists opportunities in Kenya to
produce 20 Gigabytes of wind power 10
gigawatts of geothermal electricity and
being at the equator considerable amount
of solar energy
green energy production opportunities
are vast in Kenya and throughout Africa
in the East Africa alone for example
there exists sufficient hydroelectric
potential to produce a hundred thousand
megawatts and if properly exploited
could generate enough clean energy for
the whole of the continent
instead of struggling to power
industrialization using dirty energy
which is costly and destroying our
planet we want to make a case for
developed economies to decarbonize their
production by directing industrial
Investments to Africa and making use of
clean energy to manufacture for the
whole world
Corp 26 established the classical
dialogue to formulate funding
arrangements for measures to prevent
mitigate and remedy loss and damage
associated with adverse effects of
climate change
loss and damage is not an abstract topic
of endless dialogue it is our daily
experience and the living nightmare of
millions of Kenyans and hundreds of
millions of Africans
are phenomenal of rising water levels in
Rift Valley LX was experienced in Kenya
in 2020 and generated humanitarian
crisis of unprecedented levels
approximately 75 000 households were
displaced in 13 counties with a total
population of 379
000 requiring
urgent humanitarian assistance
the affected communities endure
disruption for their livelihoods losing
homes gracing grazing lands and farming
Fields while social amenities like
schools Health Facilities markets fish
Landings and processing facilities once
thriving hotels curio shops Resorts and
lodges electricity lines
and water supply and sanitation units
were swallowed by water bodies
loss and damage must therefore be
addressed with a level of seriousness
which demonstrates fairness
urgency and consideration
Africa contributes less than three
percent of the pollution responsible for
climate change but its most severely
impacted by the ensuing crisis
Africa
and it is therefore only fair and proper
that this conference takes necessary
measures to recognize Africa's special
needs and circumstances under the Paris
agreement in line with the convention
and relevant decisions adopted by
previous cops
beyond the overdue legitimate and
priority concerns of resilience
mitigation loss and damage Africa offers
unique potential to play an
indispensable positive role in the
planet's climate change future
Africa's vast trucks of land deep
Treasures of diverse natural resources
tremendous untapped renewable energy
potential under youthful Dynamic and
skilled Workforce constitute the
consonants irresistible credentials
properly deployed these assets could be
crucial in driving Global mitigation
efforts while creating new economic
opportunities in the continent
I am convinced of the need to more
comprehensively showcase the
opportunities that abound in Africa such
as green Energy Smart agriculture the
carbonized manufacturing
immobility and Green Building all aimed
at the attainment of zero carbon by
2050.
as the coordinator of the committee of
African heads of state and governments
on climate change I therefore plan to
convince a continental Summit focusing
on climate action next year accordingly
you are all invited to take part in
Africa's march to sustainable economic
transformation and green growth
Kenya's next significance export will be
carbon credits this is why we call for
simplified more transparent carbon
Market systems that directly benefit
communities and not just intermediaries
back home I just launched an ambitious
project to increase the national tree
cover from the current 12 percent to 30
percent in 10 years we intend to
accomplish this by fast growing 15
billion trees on approximately
10.6 million hectares of land through
the throughout the country at an
estimated cost of U.S dollars 500
million
in conclusion excellencies ladies and
gentlemen in the face of impending
catastrophe whose warning signs are
already unbearably disastrous weak
action is unwise no action is dangerous
at this point in the progression of This
calamity we have few choices and little
time
our discourse must focus on delivery and
our conversation must be centered on our
commitments and implementation
I call on every delegate here today to
rise to the challenge of this moment to
make difficult but necessary decisions
and seize transformative opportunity
from the grasp of climate disaster
this means honoring spending commitments
for mitigation and adaptation and
mobilizing increased Financial flows to
those affected especially in Africa
by keeping our promises and being bound
by our word
we will demonstrate to people across the
globe that their leaders are their
honest
agents and true guarantors
cope
this is our golden chance to vindicate
present Generations who took who look to
us to lead the way in preserving our
planet and to perform our role as
Trustees of future Generations
the way things are we might never have a
more opportune time
and there might never be
a better chance
I thank you
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome is
Excellency Mr ignacious classes
president of Switzerland your Excellency
of the floor
okay
president
s
excellence
defeat
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
security
[Music]
foreign
a Glasgow
lipis is
[Music]
[Music]
is objective
climatic Depot
the reduction drastic the missions
adaptations
foreign
[Music]
acidity
in coordination first remote
a difficile May fundamental
ISM objectives
foreign
[Music]
foreign
scientific
is
the capacity foreign
demo
foreign
[Music]
development
is
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Majestic King tropu the sixth the king
of Tonga your majesty you have the floor
your majesties your highnesses Secretary
General
your Excellency at the Fatal CC
president of the Arab Republic of Egypt
excellencies distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen
please accept my sincere congratulations
and best wishes on your presidency of
the 27th session of the conference of
parties to the United Nations framework
convention on climate change
the opportunity is also taken to commend
the
unfccc Secretariat and staff
for their Timeless efforts and
impeccable preparation to facilitate
this conference
I would like to thank the government of
Egypt and the City of charmele Sheikh
for your warm Hospitality since our
arrival in the beautiful city of peace
Mr President 30 years ago the United
Nations chartered a course in adopting
the United Nations framework convention
on climate change
and in 2015 we gave this journey a new
result in the Paris agreement at Copper
26 in Glasgow parties increased ambition
and kept the hope of 1.5 degrees alive
we acknowledge and commend the outcomes
of copper 26 and note that we will only
be a step closer to our goals if every
country delivers on their pledges
we are here to make progress from where
we stood with Glasgow climate Pact
and more importantly with the
commitments we made at the adoption of
the Paris agreement
a theme chosen for the 27th session of
the conference of parties delivering for
people and the planet
is both a timely and an essential
reminder of the urgency of the task at
hand for the survival of the earth and
for us its inhabitants
our task in delivering for our people
and our planet is to agree to goals with
the highest ambition possible and to act
together and before the impacts become
irreversible for us all of us
we no longer have the luxury of time
the inherent physical attributes of our
islands in the Pacific Ocean make
climate change the single greatest
threat that will determine the future of
small island developing States like the
Kingdom of Tonga
my kingdom is the third most vulnerable
country in the world to the adverse
effects of climate change
as a people we share a deep connection
to the ocean as of many other Pacific
island countries tongai is heavily
dependent upon its fisheries and ocean
resources for food transport Economic
Development and culture
historically the Tongan people have
always shown resilience in the face of
such natural disasters
however the record rates have increased
Coastal erosion ocean acidification and
loss of coral reefs coupled with
ever-present rising sea levels three
times higher than the global average
our ability to respond to the increasing
multiplicity of disasters and the
increasing severity and intensity of
extreme weather patents is now
undermined
on the 15th of January this year
Tonga experienced a volcanic explosion
equal to none in our living history
homes were destroyed lives were lost and
entire communities are deeply
traumatized by Sonic explosions and the
resulting tsunami waves
population displacement has now become a
permanent feature for my people
in the aftermath of the explosion we
experience the care compassion and
support of the global community and our
neighboring countries in response and
Recovery efforts Mr President I would
like to take this opportunity to thank
each and every one of you who have made
a contribution to the recovery efforts
of my people
I acknowledge your kindness and the
compassion shown towards the people of
the Kingdom of Tonga
please allow me to highlight two key
future challenges resulting from this
unprecedented volcanic explosion
the first is our access to clean safe
drinking water
the pollution of rain water in the
aftermath of the explosion highlighted
the vulnerability of water storage sites
in the outer Islands
this urgent reality places greater
importance on the access to available
water desalination technologies that can
operate on renewable energy
[Music]
the Second Challenge as an ocean state
is to offer affordable transportation
that does not add to our greenhouse gas
emissions
our culture and history as people of the
ocean has taught us to live in harmony
with our environment
in the near future we will need to
reacquaint our people with such
livelihoods and use cutting-edge
Technologies
that promote wind powered low carbon
emitting modes of transport
a small island developing States we
cannot face the challenges presented to
all of us alone we are firmly committed
to International goals in 2020 the
government of Tonga submitted its second
nationally determined contribution under
the Paris agreement setting ambitious
mitigation and adoption goals
in addition tonga's long-term low
emission development strategy sets
Targets in sectors including energy
transport waste management and the
resettlement of communities
Global objectives must be directly
translated into our mission and journey
charting a pathway for a resilient
sustainable and inclusive future for
Tonga
such goals and measures also support the
implementation of the Tonga climate
change policy from 2016 and uphold the
overarching goal of a climate change
resilient Tonga by 2035.
for small island developing States like
Tonga adoption to climate change
generates larger benefits
when delivered in conjunction with other
development activities such as disaster
risk reduction and community-based
approaches to development
my kingdom shares the concerns of other
countries
in the Pacific Islands Forum in some
solidarity we endorsed the 2050 strategy
for the Blue Pacific continent
that highlights the challenges that we
face as a region and it symbolizes our
drive to respond to our ever-changing
environment
as the impacts of climate change are
intergenerational and our actions and
decisions today will have a major
bearing on the future of our people I'm
encouraged by the agendas at cop27 over
the coming days
I hope that all of us here present will
be inspired motivated and driven into
action on firm commitments a sense of
shared responsibility and connection
with the global community
this will be a testament to the genuine
Partnerships of all parties in raising
Ambitions and actions towards achieving
the goals of the parents agreement
may we always keep in mind the impacts
of our decisions and actions here at
cop27
as we chart our course towards a
successful prosperous and sustainable
future a future where the well-being
survival and peace of future Generations
are their inheritance thank you
[Music]
foreign
for your statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr edges Levites president of
Latvia your Excellency you have the
floor
Mr President
distinguished delegates
I thank Egypt and president sisi for
hosting the cop 27 meeting the higher
level of attendance points the urgent
need for this Gathering
the effects of climate change are felt
throughout the world for example in
Somalia more frequent drought has led to
farming in Pakistan melting glitches
have caused floating of a third of the
country's territory
from Greece to Australia to U.S extreme
temperatures cause extensive wildfires
in Latvia my country climate change is
decreasing biological diversity
to make matters worse
Russia's illegal war in Ukraine directly
impacts food and energy security the
environment and distracts attention of
risks and resources from climate actions
geographical location income level and
gender matters
it is our duty to protect and empower
the community's most vulnerable and
least responsible for climate change
the current energy crisis caused by
Russia's war against Ukraine is another
big up call that we need to speed up
transition to renewable energy
Green Solutions not only contribute to
the mitigation efforts but also ensure
greater energy security
in Latvia they are diversifying our
Energy Mix by accelerating wind energy
projects
we are determined to reach climate
neutrality by 2050.
Latvia is committed to the European
Union's Target of reducing greenhouse
gas emissions by at least 55 percent
until 2030.
at a local level two large Latvian
cities Riga and leapaya aim to be among
the first 100 climate neutral cities in
Europe by 2030.
Collective problems need Collective
Solutions
and these Solutions must be based on
just transition
just transition is a keyword of this
conference
effective climate governance requires
close cooperation between government
business the scientific community and
Civil Society especially Civil Society
in Latvia too we are determined to
further improve our climate governance
mechanism
Mr President cop 27 should be aimed at
bridging our differences and mitigation
adaptation loss and damage and climate
Finance
delay in the mitigation efforts will
only increase the need for adaptation
measures and financial resources
the outcome of fairness Sheikh he must
be an ambitious comprehensive Global
Response to climate change
already said the world needs a pact
between developed emerging and
developing economies in order to save
our planet
thank you
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Gustavo Francisco Pedro
Reco president of Colombia your
Excellency you have the floor
climatico
Simon still presidential Republic
Ministries
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
matica
petroleum carbon igas
para planet
[Music]
[Music]
implica
de consumer petroleum carbon yes
economia
[Music]
Manila
[Music]
Al final
the Colombia
is
climatica
Las conferences
Domina
is
that
is mercados
[Music]
Uno
La um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Del planeta
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
siete
climatica
important
organizations
foreign
del Mundo David financ
ES
[Music]
propane
gracias
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency
president of the Republic of Zambia your
Excellency of the floor
thank you very much
your Excellency
Mr Abdel CC president of the Republic of
Egypt Arab Republic of Egypt
your excellencies fellow heads of state
and government
United Nations Secretary General
your Excellency Mr Simon Steele
executive secretary of the UN framework
convention on climate change
distinguished delegates ladies and
gentlemen first it's our duty to
congratulate the Egyptian president
president sisi for hosting this
cop 27 conference and also to thank the
Egyptian people
for your warm Hospitality since we
arrived here
president
distinguished delegates
with the African continent being host to
this cop 27 on a continent which is most
affected by climate change obviously
together with other less developed
countries
and is befitting to call this the
African yet Global cup 27.
because
it is option
for us to say things that we probably
have not said before
now that the conference Corp 27 is half
is happening on our continent
a continent that is bearing quite a lot
of the band branch of the climate change
yet it contributes the least to climate
damage we expect that this cup 27 will
address some of our key issues that are
arising from the climate change negative
effect Mr President distinguished the
delegates our governments
home in Zambia has demonstrated the
market commitment to combat climate
change in line with the requirements of
the Paris agreement
however in order for us to be able to
maximize
own our contributions to ameliorating
the negative effects of climate change
and yet at the same time meeting our
people's minimum requirements to
maintain their livelihoods we need
strong and enduring International
partnership and support which deliver on
its commitments I think the key word
here is to deliver on our commitments
the commitments of us of course the
commitments of our partners as chair of
the African group of negotiators Zambia
has submitted an ambitious revised and
updated nationally determined
contribution as required by the Paris
agreement Mr President
distinguished delegates climate change
at session Remains the top priority for
all of us without exception therefore we
expect that cop 27 will deliver a
milestone outcome in advancing the work
program of the global goal on adaptation
that we adopted in cop 26 last year in
Glasgow Mr President
distinguished delegates while we
continue to age for the world to
increase its commitment and more
importantly delivery towards climate
change Zambia will continue to do what
it's able to do in its own right given
its resource constraints we have
identified a number of mitigation
actions as a means of attaining our
aspirations and increasing our
commitment we continue to formulate to
formulate green growth strategies which
will provide the framework for
transforming the country into a climate
smart green economy
Mr President distinguished delegates we
call on all our esteemed Partners to
fulfill their pledge of a hundred
billion dollars
per year of funding for us all to meet
our intended goals around this challenge
climate change this is a very important
motivation for us all to continue with
our climate change mitigation efforts in
addition to honestly speaking to making
this contribution commitment obligation
meet met as a measure of
credibility that we don't meet our
commitments we make the various
commitments we don't meet them obviously
our credibility as the individual
countries but also as a group of Nations
A League of Nations Global League of
Nations
is at question and I believe that will
address this issue
after this cop 27. we have an obligation
and a noble task to deliver for the
future generations for our planet
especially that we are meeting here once
more on the African continent
as we conclude Mr President fellow
delegates there are times when we as
individual countries have a decision to
support or not to support certain
commitments in this particular case I'm
afraid to say that option to decide not
to does not exist is not available to
any one of us
it is important therefore for us to
accept and understand that
a crisis like this one should not divide
us should not move us away from each
other it does not matter what
discussions we're having individually in
our countries it does not matter what
issues face us as regions as continents
but also as a global Community we have
an obligation to work together and
cooperate even more than ever before and
this way is the most assured way of
defeating the negative effects of
climate change as I said let us come out
of this cop 27 more united and work
together in many spheres including
joint Investments
trading making carbon trading as is
as is possible and we shouldn't leave
the Ascension steps to carbon trading
for example to individual states let's
work out a template on how to engage in
carbon trade much easier including
working on the regulations that affect
this important Revenue based activity
which will help us ameliorate the
negative effects of climate change
the president
distinguished guests a lot has been said
I choose to say these few words and ask
all of us to rededicate our efforts and
more important accelerate implementation
of mitigation factors all of us without
exception I thank you for your kindness
attention
[Applause]
I thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is now my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr smile Omar guelle
president of Japan your Excellency you
have the floor
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
contest
[Music]
s
happily parallel numbers
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
measure
the subconscious resilience
[Music]
[Music]
security or resources
substances
[Music]
solar research
ERS
problematic dischargement climatic
Cedar City is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the mission
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
alert
is
foreign
Africa
the preoccupation
event
La definition the novel objective
Collective cantify the finances
the best one the pays and development do
in definition Club the mechanisms
it is
that
language the principle is a material or
objective the reduction of the guys I
felt they said I am Ferguson degrees
Celsius
in transition energetic just inclusive
equitable
Intel transition
the exploration resources energetics
monsieur
de la freak is
a demographic
is
foreign
so foreign
conception is
now
[ __ ] you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Miller jukanovic president
of Montenegro
your Excellency you have the floor thank
you
excellencia
trust me the sovereign
foreign
system
excellencia
is
foreign
no crime
is
foreign
excellencia
that is
almost
foreign
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Rashad Muhammad Ali
al-alini president of Yemen
your Excellency you have the floor
simulator
say the rice
say that wasada
was
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
foreign foreign
Irani
um
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Rishi sunak prime minister
of the United Kingdom of Great Britain
and Northern Ireland your Excellency you
have the floor
when her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
addressed cop 26 last year
she reflected how history has shown
that when Nations come together in
common cause
there is always room for hope
I believe we found room for Hope in
Glasgow
with one last chance to create a plan
that would limit Global temperature
rises to 1.5 degrees
we made the promises to keep that goal
Within Reach
and the question today is this
can we summon the collective will to
deliver them
I believe we can
when we began our cop presidency just
one third of the global economy was
signed up to Net Zero today it is 90
percent
and for our part the UK which was the
first major economy in the world to
legislate for Net Zero will fulfill our
ambitious commitment to reduce emissions
by at least 68 percent by 2030.
and because there is no solution to
climate change without protecting and
restoring nature
in Glasgow more than 140 countries which
are home to over 90 percent of the
world's forests
made a historic promise to Halt and
reverse Forest loss and land degradation
by the end of this decade
and just this afternoon I co-hosted the
first meeting of the forests and climate
leaders partnership to ensure this is
delivered
Central to all our efforts is honoring
our promises on climate Finance I know
that for many finances are tough right
now
the pandemic all but broke the global
economy
and before coming here today I spent
last week working on the difficult
decisions needed to ensure confidence
and economic stability in my own country
but I can tell you today that the United
Kingdom is delivering on our commitment
of 11.6 billion pounds and as part of
this we will now triple our funding on
adaptation to 1.5 billion pounds by
2025.
but let me tell you why
first I profoundly believe it is the
right thing to do
listen to prime minister Motley of
Barbados as she describes the
existential threat posed by the ravages
of climate change
or look at the devastating floods in
Pakistan
where the area underwater is the same
size as the entire United Kingdom
when you see 33 million people displaced
with disease Rife and spreading through
the water
you know it is morally right to honor
our promises
but it is also economically right too
climate security goes hand in hand with
energy security
Putin's abhorrent war in Ukraine and
Rising Energy prices across the world
are not a reason to go slow on climate
change
they are a reason to act faster
because diversifying our energy supplies
by investing in Renewables is precisely
the way to ensure ourselves against the
risks of energy dependency
it is also a fantastic source of new
jobs and growth
in Glasgow we began an approach globally
using Aid funding to unlock billions of
pounds of private Finance for the
development of new green infrastructure
so instead of developing countries being
unfairly burdened with the carbon debt
of richer Nations and somehow expected
to forego that same path to growth
we are helping those countries deliver
their own fast track to clean growth
and the UK is making further commitments
to support this today including by
investing 65 million pounds in a range
of green investment projects in Kenya
and in Egypt
I'd like to pay tribute to president
CeCe for his leadership in bringing us
all together
and to thank the UK's president of cop26
alok Sharma for his inspiring work to
deliver on the Paris agreement and
Glasgow climate Pact
by honoring the promises we made in
Glasgow and by directing public and
private Finance towards the protection
of our planet
we can turn our struggle against climate
change into a global mission for new
jobs and clean growth
and we can bequeath our children A
Greener planet and a more prosperous
future
that's a legacy we could be proud of
so as we come together once again in
common cause today
there really is room for hope
together
let us fulfill it thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr vahren kachaturian
President of Armenia
your Excellency you have the floor
foreign
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
first of all let me express my gratitude
to the president of the Arab Republic of
Egypt
his Excellency Abdul update
and the government of Egypt
for an excellent organization of this
conference
foreign
Sunday
is
Channel
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr barut pahar president of
Slovenia
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you Mr President ladies and
gentlemen
I could not wish for a better platform
from which to address the world
for my very last time in the capacity of
the president of the Republic of
Slovenia
I express my sincere gratitude to Egypt
for its hospitality and for its tireless
efforts to make cop 27 a success
ladies and gentlemen
climate breakdown is the essential issue
of our times both globally and locally
personally I am deeply committed to
protecting our environment with my own
standing committee for climate policy
all excellent experts on the Airfield I
regularly recommend adoption of concrete
measures to the Slovenian government and
the house
colleagues and Friends
decade we live in is the critical one
for stepping up climate action
full implementation of the Paris
agreement and the Glasgow climate Pact
are our way forward in staying on track
with the 1.5 Celsius goal
we are experiencing combined energy and
food insecurity also due to the Russian
war against Ukraine
this however should not to come at the
expense of our ambitious climate action
on the contrary we should use the
current energy crisis as an opportunity
for out of the box
solutions for mitigating climate climate
change
I reiterate slovenia's ambition to reach
climate and neutrality by 2050 at the
latest
we are preparing our first National
Climate law
which will further promote meeting this
target
at the same time we are well aware of
the great diversity of needs of
developing countries and communities
we therefore wish to substantial
progress on the global goal on
adaptation
we support efforts to find solutions for
founding arrangements for loss and
damage
we also support the call of the United
Nations security General to expand early
warning coverage throughout the world
excellencies
climate breakdown is increasingly a
factor of instability
violence and War
as a candidate for a non-permanent seat
of the United Nations security Council
for the period of
2045-2025 Slovenia aims for integration
climate action into prevention peaceful
building and peacemaking we are
committed to solidarity
this year we doubled our climate Finance
through multilateral channels in support
for the least developed States and small
Islands developing States
ladies and gentlemen
climate breakdown is happening here and
now we shall either stand together all
four together we only have this one
motherland
Our Generation has the possibility and
duty to act and leave the planet in a
better shape for our children again
failure is not an option
we are talking of a man-made problem we
have a man-made solution for it so let's
get to work together for implementation
Mr President thank you for your
attention
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr isak herself president of
Israel
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you dear excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
I'm so very honored to join you today
from across the globe so many friends at
the cop 27. I thank the president of the
Arab Republic of Egypt
his Excellency
and his government for hosting us here
in this beautiful Sharma Shake
as neighboring Nations Israel and Egypt
are both fortunate to call this
beautiful region the Middle East our
home
however this home we all love is also a
global hotspot for climate change
with studies forecasting imminent severe
consequences of our region
the Middle East is on the brink of
catastrophe and you could have heard it
in the speeches of my predecessors
here in Sharma Sheikh I wish to
reiterate the state of Israel's solid
commitment as relayed last year in
Glasgow to achieving Net Zero carbon
emissions and to transitioning from
fossil fuels to renewable energy by
2050.
but Israel is prepared to assume far
greater responsibility
Israel is prepared to lead the effort
towards Regional climate resilience I
intend to spearhead the development of
what I term as renewable Middle East a
regional ecosystem of sustainable peace
I Envision that in the foreseeable
future the solar energy produced in the
deserts of the Middle East will be
available for exportation to Europe Asia
and Africa
if for example Israel and Greece are
already working on electricity
connectors to supply green electricity
from Israel to Europe
I believe that the entire Middle East
all Middle East Nations abundant with
sun and Technology will have the ability
to connect the rest of the world to a
magnificent source of renewable energy
in a region undergoing accelerated
desertification Israel also has the
capability and know-how to deflect
severe watered shortages and to offer
solutions for Foods in security
we are eager to share all our expertise
and practical tools
that is what a renewable Middle East is
all about
and I invite you all to visit our
beautiful Pavilion here at cop 27 and
see some of these brilliant ideas for
yourself
dear friends this crisis threatens the
very existence of the future which we
wish for our children
it transcends politics and Geographic
margins and so must we
I say to All Nations that the cop 27 and
particularly to our neighbors near and
far
this state of emergency
demands we work together not tomorrow
today
let us turn the climate emergency you
know and into an opportunity to address
20th Thrift Century conflicts
thereby advancing desperately needed
21st century collaborations let's let us
leverage vital Regional Partnerships
as a path towards inclusivity stability
and prosperity to form this shared
renewable Middle East
the prosperity green and prosperity blue
partnership
reflecting Jordan's intention to supply
Israel with green electricity and
Israel's intention to supply Jordan with
desalinated water with the direct
involvement and support of the United
States of America and the United Arab
Emirates is the ultimate example of
creative win-win Partnerships which will
contribute to the stability of the
entire region
in the spirit of our hosts in the region
I would like
to teach from the Quran that has said to
be good to others as Allah has been good
to us and to not seek the corrupt the
land as said in Arabic
as our Holy Bible says
may you work toil and protect the land
is
let us save the world God gave us for we
are all have been created in His image
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr umaro sisoko President of
Guinea bissau
foreign
foreign
foreign
eventim
correspondent I own this View
equivalent that means
yours
foreign
foreign
Plaza
Orange
because you know it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
principles
foreign
foreign
energetica
how long is
the plane implementation sounds
[Music]
foreign
African
um
the foreign
[Music]
foreign
residuals
is
windows
Renaissance
foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Imam Ali Rahman president
of Tajikistan
your Excellency you have the floor
Motors
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
Kardashian
[Music]
s
office
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
for all
the Dory was
as is
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Pedro Sanchez Perez casino
president of the government of Spain
your Excellency you have the floor
is
foreign
De Los Angeles
foreign
pace
is
disappears
important difference
foreign
certification
Opera
is
contributions
Rehabilitation is
energetica
muchas
thank you your Excellency
thank you
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr maruth Amin vice president
of Indonesia
your Excellency you have the floor
planetary crisis
Ama
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
Indonesia
one took lead by example
determine contribution
Indonesia
then International
foreign
energy Indonesia
country
platform for energy transition mechanism
infestation energy
foreign
inclusive
Indonesia continuous
the beginning
foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr timoko
Vice President of Cote d'Ivoire
your Excellency you have the floor
messy celebrated
presidential Republic Arab digits
excellence
foreign
[Music]
foreign
excellence
Madame dementia
decided
contribution determination
[Music]
planet
trance
foreign
natural
a little directors electricity or solar
air abdomas
Excellence Madame dementia
the situation geopolitical demand Menace
a kid do not root control the rest of my
climatic
Visions energetic
objectives
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Faisal Nasim Vice
President of Maldives
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you president
your Excellency Mr Abdul fatah so you
see
president of the Arab Republic of Egypt
your Excellency Mr Antonio gutaris
Secretary General of the United Nations
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
I would like to thank the government and
the people of Egypt for hosting cop 27
in such a breathtaking location
all of us can learn from Egypt's Rich
history and ancient civilization about
how Humanity can create wonderful
Marvels with creativity and ingenuity
once again we gather here together to
strengthen our commitment
to climate action the stake could not be
higher
climate change has already remade the
world in ways that we could not imagine
just a few years ago
we need to act decisively to fully
address the climate emergency
if we look back just at the last six
months
the floods in Pakistan have wreaked
havoc
you raising years of development and
causing over a thousand deaths
Europe has experienced its worst heat
wave ever
here in the African continent people
have failed the combine effects of the
Ukraine war and climate change where 82
million people are now acutely food
insecure
these effects are felt more strongly
by the most vulnerable members of
societies especially women and children
in the Maldives
our lives are also affected daily by
climate change because the ocean is
changing
the ocean is our nation's source of
nourishment
and income
each year our official may need to
travel further and further to find
abundant Fisheries
unpredictable Monsoon shifts have risen
in frequency
and intensity
causing Storm surges and flooding that
have had irreparable damage to property
and livelihoods
our coral reefs drove into tourists from
around the world around life support
and every single Island
has lost this fresh water supply
so we are dependent on technology to
provide fresh water
yet our contribution to the cause of
climate change is negligible
and so is without Global solidarity
our ability to respond to these changes
we come to cope
to address this Injustice
our story is not unique to the Maldives
but Echoes In All seafaring Nations
indeed all nations of the world
as the ocean changes so do we
we are truly at a Crossroads
we have only 86 months to have emissions
and keep the temperature increase below
1.5 degrees time is
very short
at this cup
we expect
ambitious commitments on mitigation
including more parties
aggressively phasing out fossil fuels
and making the just transition
to renewable energy sources
a clear path towards articulating the
global goal
on adaptation that focuses on key
transpoundary issues such as water food
security
health and biodiversity
a bold and Visionary outcome on loss and
damage that provides a mosaic of
solutions
to address a complex set of problems
to meet our Collective goal of 100
billion US dollar per year in climate
Finance with more than half dedicated to
adaptation
to fully implement the police agreement
we also need to increase
ambition outside of the UNF Triple C
all International financial institutions
need to align their policies with the
Paris agreement
we congratulate the IMF for
operationalizing the resilience and
sustainability trust and also
congratulate Barbados for its breakdown
agenda
the World Bank can also play an
important role by relaxing its current
capital restaurant to increase its
lending capacity
lead in the way towards a decarbonized
world
excellencies
climate change is remaking the world
it's our responsibility and why we have
gathered here
to ensure that the remade world is
Equitable just an allows all of us to
live well
I thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr badara Vice President of
Gambia
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you very much
presidents
distinguished ladies and gentlemen your
excellencies
on behalf of this Excellency president
Adam mubaro the government and the
people of The Gambia
we wish to extend our gratitude
to his Excellency president Cece and the
people of Egypt and the government of
Egypt for inviting The Gambia to this
auspicious occasion and also for the
gratitude that is extended to the
gambian delegation
Mr President The Gambia is on track to
meet
sdg-13 on climate action
our ndc2 was acknowledged to be
ambitious and in compliance with Article
4 paragraph 6 and 19 of the Paris
agreement
The Gambia has also submitted its
strategy for becoming climate neutral by
2050 called The Gambia long time climate
neutral development strategy 2050 LTS to
the United Nations framework convention
on climate change available for viewing
in the on their websites
the LTS focuses on the country's
five key Greenhouse emitting sectors on
both mitigation and adaptations actions
and require an estimated about 4 billion
US dollars for implementation against
2050.
to support the unconditional targets of
our ndcs The Gambia government has
increased allocation in its National
budgets and also working with private
sector and development partners
such as the World Bank the EU and others
to address climate change
both in the areas of adaptation
resilience mitigation and renewable
energy
by 2025
The Gambler will have more than 30 MV
solar power plants to reduce the cost of
buying and using fossil fuel
The Gambia being a small and low-lying
Country
bisect by the river Gambia our greatest
risk is the sea level rise
posing potentially a great existential
risk particularly to the capital banjul
which is below sea level
this year's floors and the wind storms
of last year cause enormous destruction
to life and livelihood and property
putting much pressure on our Amiga
National budgets and also on achieving
the sdgs
pledges of financial support alone are
not sufficient
we need practical Financial commitments
easily accessible without much
procedural difficulties and challenges
like many ldcs the gambia's negligible
contribution to Global emission of
greenhouse gas is less than 0.01 percent
but took a lead to respond to the global
call for Action to prepare an ambitious
ndc2 meeting the Paris agreements
temperature globe globe I mean goal of
1.50 Celsius
this is a clear indication of the
highest level of political will and
commitment
We join orders to call on developed
countries to make good on their promise
on climate financing
developed Nations that have contributed
more to the accumulation of greenhouse
gas emissions should take a lead
responsibility to finance the climate
crisis with reference to the Paris
agreement and article 2. we now need
committed actions for Urgent
implementation to make here in Sherman
Sheikh
Mr President I would like to draw on the
moral of two
stories that we have
one is that there were two sets of
groups of people some of them very lean
and hungry looking with arms two meters
long and spoons to meet us long
the others are fat and healthy looking
with arms two meters long and spoons two
meters long and the question was posed
why are you so thin they said because
they have arms two meters long and they
could not feed and the second group that
is fat and good looking they were asked
the same question and they said they
feed each other the moral of their story
is together for the implementation of
climate plan that we have we can survive
and save the planet the other is Usain
bolts Run 100 meters in 9.5
the Jamaican 400 meters team ran it in
9.2 so Usain bolts in the Jamaican team
together run 9.2 but alone he ran 9.5 so
as a team with commitments and
cooperation and determination working
together for the implementation of the
Paris agreement it means we are on
course to win the climate gold medal and
we will prevail thank you
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome our
Excellency Miss Esperanza Maria
Francisco Dacosta vice president of
Angola
your Excellency you have the floor
thank you Mr President
IAL
studied governor
distincts confidence president
is
[Music]
transversal
is
silences
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome Her
Excellency
Joshua Maloney prime minister of Italy
your Excellency you have the floor
well president alsizi Mr Secretary
General
to your colleagues
we are at the decisive moment in the
fight against climate change
over the last few months we have
experienced its dramatic effects
throughout Europe and Pakistan in the
Horn of Africa and in many other regions
of a planet
we are all called upon to make deeper
and faster Force
to protect our planet our common home
in doing so
we will have to keep people at the heart
and transform accordingly
combining environmental economic and
social sustainability
despite a very complex International
scenario
already affected by the pandemic and
further disrupted by the Russian
aggression against Ukraine
easily remains strongly committed to
pursuing its decarbonization pathway
in full compliance with the goals of the
Paris agreement
we want to develop our energy
diversification strategy in close
collaboration with several African
countries
with whom we have enhanced our
cooperation on energy security
Renewables and youth education
this will stimulate green growth drug
creation and the development of sustain
sustainable value chains
in the EU we plan to reintroduce the The
Green House gas emissions by at least 55
percent by 2030 and to achieve climate
neutrality by 2050 at the latest
in this perspective
Italy has recently strengthened its
Renewable Power installed capacity
and will accelerate this trend in line
with the objectives of repower you
we intend to pursue a just transition to
support the affected communities and
leave no one behind
last year the Italian G20 presidency
reached concrete results that paved the
way from for the agreements in Glasgow
aspiring a partner of the United Kingdom
for cop 26 we promoted the youth for
climate events in order to involve young
Generations in the decision-making
process processes on climate change
Italy has also significantly increased
its contribution to climate Finance
we have almost tripled our financial
commitment to 1.4 billion dollar for the
next five years
including
840 Millions Euro through the new
Italian climate fund
this is the first Italian investment
platform specifically dedicated to the
deployment of clean Technologies and to
adaptation to climate change in
developing countries
we remain committed
to deliver on the 100 billion dollar
pledge to support developing countries
through 2025 and to Define an ambitious
and sustainable Target thereafter
to do so
we must bring together governments
private investors and multilateral
development Banks to co-share
Investments and risks to accelerate
adjust energy transition
Italy is proud to be part of the Just
Energy transition partnership and
ambitious G7 initiative that will
provide substantial financial resources
and technical assistance to partner
countries
recent climate disasters a special
especially
hydrogeological disruption to our
territory
show that mitigation and adaptation are
these two sides of the same kind
Italy is therefore balancing its
financial support to both priorities
in 2020
56 percent of our overall climate
Finance has devoted to adaptation
measures
while the remaining 44 percent
went towards mitigation
fighting climate change
is a common endeavor
which requires the fuel engagement of
all countries and pragmatic cooperation
among all major Global actors
unfortunately we have to admit
that this is not happening
we cannot hide the fact that the nation
that are most committed to these goals
risk paying a price
to the advantage of those that today are
mostly responsible for CO2 Emissions on
the planet
this is paradoxical
and measures are needed to redress these
imbalances
our efforts are wise will be vain
and the Very outcome of events such as
the one we are attending today risks not
to produce the results of that history
expects from all of us
As Leaders we owe this to our future
Generations
since our commitment to protect the
environment as part of our identity is
the most Vivid example
of the alliance between those who are
here those who were here and those who
will come after us
Italy will provide its fair share thank
you
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Olaf Schultz Chancellor of
the Federal Republic of Germany
your Excellency you have the floor
foreign
foreign
politics
political imperative
English
it is
on that serious Essence
programs for standing
program is
Titans
foreign
[Music]
foreign
mobilization
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
and stuff kind of built by the
Renaissance
is
yeah
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Mark rotten Prime Minister
of Netherlands
your Excellency you have the floor
Mr President
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
one and a half degrees
that was our legitimate ambition in
Paris
but seven years old we are lacking
seriously behind
the action we have taken so far has been
way too little
way too late
we are far beyond the point of new
Ambitions and Promises
we need to step up and rapidly deliver
on the Promises we've made
the Netherlands is taking its
responsibility
my country will reduce its carbon
emissions by 55 to 60 percent in this
decade
this will not be easy
and we still have a great deal of work
to make it happen
but we must do it
so we are investing significantly in
renewable energy resources
such as hydrogen
and offshore wind both at home and
abroad
and at the same time we are helping
others
vulnerable countries are rightly
concerned about loss and damage caused
by other countries emissions
that's certainly the reality for our
African friends and partners
to them I say
I hear your call for greater solidarity
the African continent is on the front
line of a climate emergency it did not
create
an emergency that has fueled food
insecurity this year made even worse by
Russia's unprovoked aggression against
Ukraine
for the sake of Africa and for the whole
world
we need to do more to deal with the
lasting effects of climate change
those effects can't be undone even with
our best effort
to boost our resilience we need to adapt
now
of course all this requires money
so the Netherlands will increase its
annual contribution to the 100 billion
dollar pledge to 1.8 billion euros by
2025.
and as part of this increase
we will double our Public Finance for
climate adaptation
including 100 million euros for the
Africa adaptation
acceleration program
all this money needs to go to those hit
hardest by climate change
ladies and gentlemen the king of the
Netherlands consists of a low-lying
Delta country on the North Sea and
several small island states in the
Caribbean
we know from long experience that water
weather too much too little or too
polluted is De Factor linking the great
challenges of our time
what's more
ninety percent of all climate disasters
manifest themselves through water
fire flooding drought or pollution
that's why the U.N 2023 Water conference
next march is so important
this conference which we are co-hosting
with Tajikistan will be all about water
action
I urge you all to be there
and her urge you to deliver on every
climate action promise you've made
I urge you to amplify the voices of
women
and young people worldwide
because they are still underrepresented
when it comes to decision making on
climate change
we still have a long way to go
but I promise you this
you can count on the Netherlands
just as we are counting on you
thank you
thank you your Excellency
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr oath christerson prime
minister of Sweden
your Excellency you have the floor
foreign
Secretary General Mr President ladies
and gentlemen
I would like to start by reaffirming
kazakhstan's solid and continued
commitment to the goals and objectives
of the Paris agreement
as you know our country has set out the
ambitious Target of achieving Net Zero
by 2060.
as part of this we are planning to adopt
our first ever low carbon development
strategy by the end of this year
this will Mark a historic moment the
first time a country in Central Asia has
laid out such an ambitious document
this strategy will update our nationally
determined contributions
in it we will pledge to achieve an
unconditional 15 reduction of our carbon
emissions by 2030.
we have also set a conditional Target of
25 percent that relies on the
possibility of additional support from
International partners
currently green energy represents three
percent of kazakhstan's total energy
Supply
we have set a target of increasing our
renewable energy Supply to 15 percent
that is at least seven additional
gigawatts by 2030.
Kazakhstan has the potential to be a
global green energy Powerhouse
therefore we are ready to act as a
regional hub for Renewables and to drive
Central Asia's green transition
green hydrogen will play play a k role
in this transition
International experts believe that our
country can become one of the 10 largest
hydrogen exporters
in addition Kazakhstan has an unique
role to play in the global energy
transition thanks to its significant
reserves of critical raw materials and
elements
our country holds more than 60 major
deposits of precious and non-ferrous
metals
We Stand ready to offer these critical
resources for exploration and
development
as well as investing in the future of
the energy transition we are also taking
argument action to mitigate our carbon
emissions
underpinning this effort the national
emissions trading system has already
proved to Be an Effective mechanism for
stimulating Innovations in both
emissions reduction and Energy
Efficiency
separately I would like to mention the
importance of technological
modernization there is a critical need
to leverage knowledge sharing and
Technology transfer including within the
Paris agreement
therefore we are developing a framework
which will help Kazakhstan to adapt the
best available practices from around the
world in green technologies at the same
time we are devoting special attention
to stimulating green investment
we are prepared to use the Asana
International Financial Center as a
unique Regional investment hub for green
Finance
gear participants today the temperature
in Central Asia is increasing twice as
fast as the global average
to meet the Urgent demands created by
rapid global warming we have significant
adaptation efforts underway within our
new environmental code
the focus is on the four most vulnerable
sectors water agriculture forestry and
disaster risk reduction
last year we joined the Declaration on
forests
and land use and the commitment to
education and yes involvement
we are also on track to meet our
ambitious Target of planting 2 billion
trees by 2025.
ladies and gentlemen to conclude I would
like once again to highlight the scale
of the unprecedented challenges we face
in this regard we require both Solutions
and development models that are fair
Equitable and sustainable
Kazakhstan is ready to collaborate with
all International Partners across the
entire climate agenda thank you
I thank his Excellency Mr Ali Khan
smilov prime minister of Kazakhstan for
his statement and I apologize for the
mistake in the announcement
it is
it is my pleasure to welcome Her
Excellency Miss Sana Marin prime
minister of Finland
your Excellency you have the floor
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
I would like to thank Egypt for hosting
us here on the African continent where
many of the impacts of climate change
are felt most traumatically
while all of us suffer the consequences
of climate change it is the poorest and
most vulnerable who suffer the most
I assure you that we are determined to
find joint Solutions
the science is clear if we do not act
now this is only a preview what is to
come
this is the critical decade each year
and each action count
climate change is the biggest Global
Security challenge we face however
ongoing Wars and violence in different
parts of the world are magnifying its
impacts
also in Europe we are witnessing grave
violations of international law and the
U.N Charter which undermine
International Security and stability and
adore our capacity to work together to
find solutions to persisting Global
problems
Russ's attacked on Ukraine is a serious
breach of the u.nation charter Russ's
illegal War affects not only Ukraine but
also the entire world-based
International order right when we should
be acting together against the great
challenges of our times
it is Russia's war of aggression that
has caused the global food and energy
crisis
now more than ever we need
multilateralism to take quick and
effective action against climate change
and to ensure food and energy security
a green energy transition away from
fossil fuels is not only an answer to
climate change but also to energy
security
we must make sure this transition
happens in a trust way creating new jobs
and better opportunities for people
everywhere
I also want to stress thus we cannot
implement the goals of the Paris
agreement without a joint effort from
both public and private Finance
therefore this issue too deserves its
place on the agenda
my own country Finland has set one of
the most ambitious climate Targets in
the world
we aim to be carbon neutral by 2035.
we have put our climate targets into law
a new Sami climate Council has set up at
an initiative of the Islamic Parliament
to contribute traditional knowledge to
the preparation of climate policy and
measures
Finland has also been vocal in evolving
women and youth in client policy making
it is crucial that all groups including
people with disabilities are able to
participate equally in the international
climate forum
Finland and the European Union are doing
their part to deliver climate Finance
Finland is particularly doubling its
climate Finance for developing countries
and taking concrete steps a part of the
champion group on adaptation Finance to
double the share of global adaptation
financing
as a co-chair of the Coalition of
Finance Finance ministers for climate
action we have promoted the integration
of finance and biodiversity action in
the National budgeting
Mr President we all agree that what we
need to do now is implementation
the longer we wait the more it will cost
so let us ensure together that this cup
is one that delivers real progress in
all areas a cop that keeps the 1.5
degree Target alive
thank you so much
thank you Excellency
thank you
distinguished heads of state and
governments delegates honored guests
this brings us to the end of our
national statements for today
we will continue with the delivery of
national statements tomorrow at 10 30
hours in this plenary
with this I declare this joint meeting
of the cop CMP and the CMA adjourned
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign